drittens geht auf und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video und ja
ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut mir auch
ihr solltet jetzt wirklich wieder
spannend das letzte video bei dass
koffer unboxing ich habe einige der
koffer die ich bei einer auktion
ersteigert alter vor du bist fast
runtergefallen kamera ich musste ich ein
bisschen 100 vorne ziehen
ich hoffe euch hier und jetzt auch judt
auf jeden fall hoffe ich die meisten von
euch haben dass koffer unboxing gesehen
was am letzten sonntag haben falls nicht
schmeckt es auf jeden fall ab ich habe
sehr viele kommentare gelesen dass viele
von euch neugierig sind auch dass
lufthansa paket wir haben hier
tatsächlich offiziell von lufthansa muss
man das geld jetzt rostock 2
das passt ja gut lufthansa-flugzeug die
lufthansa paket flugzeug vom flugzeug
aus dem flugzeug eine sachen die vom
flugzeug halt nicht mehr zurück zum
passagier gefunden habe
genau gedacht ich habe dieses paket auf
jeden fall auch von einer fundsachen
auktion online über ein auktionshaus 7
auftrag der lufthansa gruppe verlorenes
gepäck versteigern und unter anderem auf
diese boxen es gab fünf stück davon
ich glaube ein kilo dann 1,5 kilo 2,3
kilo und 7,5 kilo
ich habe hier das 2,3 kilo paket das
habe ich durch zufall gefunden einfach
noch mit geboten und konnte das dann für
330 euro
ich bleibe euch das hier super gerne mal
ein sozusagen für mich gewinnen was
schon recht vieles nennt wobei die leute
haben da direkt richtig mitgeboten
deswegen vielleicht hatten die erfahrung
so was gab's schon öfter und da sind
gute sachen drin und was ich auch noch
dazu sagen kann es ist wirklich
offiziell von lufthansa weil dieses
checks package paket bahn was hier darum
ist das gibt es nirgendwo online zu
kaufen und warum das in einem amazon
prime karton ist weiß ich mich das
bisschen unseriös natürlich aber
trotzdem wo das von lufthansa irgendwo
mal zusammengestellt und hier sollen als
sachen von passagieren
hören sein ich gehe natürlich davon aus
viel elektronik hier muss ja was an wer
drin sein
deswegen werde ich bin nur gespannt wir
zeigen das jetzt mal ab oder nicht okay
sagt ich habe ich das gute lufthansa
paket beim durchgeschnitten die koffer
option oder den koffer die ich bekomme
liefen für mich so sehr gut da war jetzt
ja einiges drauf was drin was auch ein
bisschen wert hat aber wir haben jetzt
nichts extrem krasses der ringe von wie
ein laptop oder so das liegt aber glaube
ich auch daran viele haben das
kommentiert dass diese koffer vor einmal
dann doch gecheckt werden und sachen wie
laptops geldscheine oder sachen wie
drogen damit raus genommen werden
nein ach du scheiße die haaner böses man
einfach ich bin also mit so fucking
hüten da oben drin
wollt ihr mich praxen oder was ich hoffe
für euch unter den schals hüten ist okay
wir starten einfach mal von oben
ich habe jetzt wieder keine handschuhe
aber es mir jetzt eigentlich egal
hier haben wir so ein baby strack du
scheiße das kann doch nicht euer ernst
sein dass sie in sondern lufthansa die
box einfach stimmt so sachen eindruck
wie in seinem koffer 3 130 euro das muss
man sich mal vorstellen klasse ist schon
mal nix wert dann haben wir die einen
gut ok steht keine markt dran aber nah
wird wahrscheinlich so ein hut sein denn
christa auf malle in jedem zweiten laden
für kosten die dinger 10 bis 20 euro
maximal bei amazon oder so
wahrscheinlich nicht merken
das habe ich dann gemacht ich freunde jr
das kann doch es sei noch ein hut in rot
ich habe wirklich gedacht das sind riet
das ist was ich alles also dass wir
halten fest das ist wirklich der größte
flop den ich je hatte jetzt vielleicht
eine kamera drin also hier haben wir
einmal noch kopf gehört habt ihr das von
euren scheiß piloten oder was euch damit
das sieht ja aus als wäre euer pilot von
lufthansa meint fink 1940 mit so einem
ding geflogen wer benutzt denn so was
heutzutage noch heute also dann kriege
ich ja wirklich das ist doch falsche
oder was nie wieder krieg ich mit
lufthansa
dann haben wir hier so eine extrem
hässlich also ich hab ja noch nie einen
hässlicheren bauchtasche als dass die
hier gesehen oder ist aber sogar was
drin socken und schmuck guck mal hier
haben wir sogar so eine ja dann bist du
ein goldkettchen ich weiß nicht wenn das
recht ist gold ist denn ich weiß nicht
das kann ich euch hier super gern mal
wieder ein vielleicht ist das ja was
werd ich gar nicht mal so schlecht aus
ich hoffe mal wobei wenn das wirklich
stimmt das so richtig wertvolle sachen
sei es jetzt elektronik oder dann
vielleicht auch schmuck geldscheine da
wirklich rausgefiltert werden aus den
paketen kann das ja nicht wertvoll sein
aber ich werde es natürlich trotzdem
überprüfen lassen
dann haben wir hier noch drin das ist
das denn lange keine ahnung und auch
seinen schuh als schlüsselanhänger könnt
ihr hier sehen also ja ich will mal
gerne wissen wie die person aussieht die
mit sowas rumläuft geist ist ein erster
so hast du dort geschossen
das ist nicht so etwas noch also wie man
sorry aber ich habe noch nie so eine
hässliche bauch umhängetasche gesehen
okay machen wir weiter mit einer leute
check das mal aus wir haben hier
tatsächlich von telekom eine tasse na ja
so ganz weiß ich nicht vielleicht auch
ein bisschen mit diesen auktionen so was
will ich eigentlich keinen unterschied
aber ob das alles so mit rechten dingen
zugegangen ist weiß ich nicht ein
bisschen komisch ist es ja schon und wir
hatten ja in den koffern auch zum
beispiel gar keine unterhose
das ist mir auch aufgefallen das ist ja
komisch dann keine unterhosen drin
vielleicht werden die auch vor
ausgenommen ich weiß nicht wen gegen
welchem hygiene schutzbestimmungen oder
so hier haben wir noch ein schal und
dann halten wir sollten die wahlen im
paket und das ist jetzt das einzige wo
ich mir erhofft dass es geil
also wir können sie hier sehen das ist
eine kameratasche von hama und da ist
auf jeden fall auch eine kamera drin
ich denke mal es ist so eine tory
digitalkamera aber vielleicht ist es ja
auch eine geile kamera die ein bisschen
was kostet naja so sieht die kamera aus
wir haben hier eine lumix avc hd lite hd
kamera welche ist das lumix panasonic
dmc tz7 die ist zumindest schon fünf
jahre wenn nicht sogar älter wir schauen
mal nach vielleicht hinterher noch
bilder drauf wo die jetzt sogar eine sd
karte
ich dachte ich finde jetzt paar flippige
male bilder von annette und jürgen na ja
leider nicht und dann haben wir
glücklicherweise aber auch noch ein
stativ für diese kamera ich guck mal
kurz nach wie quelle die ist aber die
wirtschaftliche wert sein
rositz effekt ich glaube es geht los
naja gut hier auf dieser seite habe ich
dir gefunden da kostet die wenigstens
noch 149 euro neu diese hier ist ja der
kriege ich maximal mich dafür kriegen
also das war wirklich der größte flop
den ich je hatte das muss man sich mal
vorstellen ich hat 330 euro + 19 euro
mehrwertsteuer plus irgendwelche
anlieferung versandkosten dafür bezahlen
also ich würde mal sagen 400 euro knapp
also bis jetzt kann ich leider kein
gutes wort verlieren über diese
kooperation wir haben noch einen fetten
damen koffer 14 kilo wiegt der dadurch
auch am meisten geld bezahlt den hatte
ich auch noch aus und wenn da auch noch
was drin ist kann ich
in diesem koffer optionen eigentlich nur
abraten oder zumindest nicht mehr als
100 euro pro pause es lohnt sich sonst
einfach nicht und dann wartet auch
lieber bis irgendwann wieder so aktionen
am frankfurter flughafen noch immer sind
das für mich auf jeden fall auch noch
mal mitmachen falls es dann geht online
ist es irgendwie ein bisschen schwierig
man weiß auch nicht ganz genau wer
bietet da ging das alles mit rechten
dingen zu wir können zwar gerne eure
meinung in die kommentare schreiben
da bin ich auf jeden fall gespannt weil
ich bin wirklich davon ausgegangen dass
wenn ich so sachen von lufthansa
ersteigerer box für 330 euro da muss
doch irgendwie auch ein handy oder sonst
was drin sein kameras ein laptop as ice
richtung irgendwie technik sachen aber
nicht so fakten mitte wiese hier liegen
alter natürlich vermittlungen oder diese
drecks tasche naja ist auch klar dass
man schlecht erfahrung sammelt leute ich
danke fürs zuschauen habe bisher mit
land mir und wir sehen uns am sonntag
wieder gibt es neues video vielleicht
auch schon freitag da kommt wieder was
anderes abonniert sehr gerne kanal dass
du nach oben da und